Ein Kontrollfreak
Meine Mutter ist so neugierig!
Sie ruft mich hundertmal am Tag an.
Sie will die ganze Zeit wissen, wo ich bin.
Dani! Wo bist du?
Ich bin in der Apotheke.
Wo bist du?
In der Bar.
Im Kino.
Wo bist du?
Im Restaurant.
Im Krankenhaus.
Wo bist du?
Im Supermarkt.
Im Club.
GEBÄUDE / GESCHÄFTE
Ich bin in + Dativ
in der Apotheke
in der Bar
im Kino
im Restaurant
im Krankenhaus
im Supermarkt
im Club
Meine Mutter kontrolliert mich immer!
Sie ist paranoid.
Dani! Ich bin besorgt!
Wo bist du?
Ich bin bei Tom.
Bei Katja.
Wo bist du?
Bei der Oma.
Beim Opa.
Wo bist du?
Beim Arzt.
Bei den Freunden
Wo bist du?
bei mir
Personen
Ich bin bei + Dativ
Es macht ihr nichts aus, mich zu stören.
Dani! Es ist schon spät.
Wo bist du?
Ich bin auf der Party.
Auf dem Konzert.
Auf dem Filmfestival.
VERANSTALTUNGEN
Ich bin auf + Dativ
auf der Party
auf dem Konzert
auf dem Filmfestival
Dani! Wo bist du?
Auf dem Balkon.
Wo bist du?
Auf dem Dach.
Auf dem Markt.
Wo bist du?
Auf dem Sportplatz.
OFFENE PLÄTZE
Ich bin auf + Dativ
Sie ruft mich zu den unmöglichsten Zeiten an.
Dani! Ich bin sehr beunruhigt.
Wo bist du?
Ich bin beim Essen.
Beim Lesen.
Wo bist du?
Beim Joggen.
Beim Einkaufen.
AKTIVITÄTEN
Ich bin bei + Dativ
beim Essen
beim Lesen
beim Joggen
beim Einkaufen
Sie bringt mich in peinliche Situationen.
Dani! Wo bist du?
Ich schaue immer auf die Uhr.
Ich bin auf der Bank.
Wo bist du?
Auf der Post.
An der Kasse.
Wo bist du?
An der Ecke.
an der Bushaltestelle
Wo bist du?
an der Universität
Sie macht mein Leben zu einem Albtraum.
Dani! Ich sorge mich um dich.
Wo bist du?
Ich bin am Flughafen.
Am Bahnhof.
Im Zug.
Wo bist du?
Im Flugzeug.
Auf dem Schiff.
ACHTUNG!
Es gibt Ausnahmen:
am Flughafen
am Bahnhof
im Zug
im Flugzeug
auf dem Schiff
Ich kann mich nirgends vor ihr verstecken.
Dani! Ich mache mir Sorgen um dich.
Wo bist du?
In Europa.
In Asien.
Wo bist du?
In China.
In Indien.
Wo bist du?
In London.
In Rom.
KONTINENTE / LÄNDER / STÄDTE
Es gibt Ausnahmen:
Meine Mutter ist ein Kontrollfreak.
Dani! Ich bin krank vor Sorge!
Wo bist du?
Am Meer.
Am Strand.
Wo bist du?
Auf der Insel.
Auf dem Berg.
Wo bist du?
In den Bergen.
Im Wald.
Wo bist du?
Im Weltraum.
Im Paradies.
Wo bist du?
In der Hölle.
Zu Hause!!!
ACHTUNG!
Es gibt Ausnahmen:
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum sie so nervös ist.
Mama! Ich bin bei der Arbeit!
ACHTUNG!
Es gibt Ausnahmen:
bei der Arbeit
Meine Mutter macht mich verrückt!
Ich kann nicht mehr damit leben!